so I'm going to save the question from
what is the next big question to what is
the next small question and the reason I
think it's fair to do this is because in
information technology we're not about
next big thing because you don't want
your new cell phone to be twice as big
as your old one you want it to be
smaller the world around us is made of
atoms and the quantum behavior of atoms
determines the way the world works the
quantum nature of atoms and of light
determine why the sky is blue and why
leaves are green why we use copper to
make electrical wires and oil as fuel
and not the other way around all of this
is based on the chemical properties of
molecules and atoms and light and so on
and by studying quantum mechanics
getting a better understanding of
quantum mechanics we can get a better
understanding of how the world works and
by studying quantum computing we can get
a better understanding of pawn mechanics
and again get a better understanding of
the world around us I don't really see
what can be a bigger question than that
so in terms of a census of what's in the
universe basically the atoms the stuff
that we are made out of makes up only
about four percent and that's the only
part of the universe we actually
understand the rest this dark matter we
don't know what it is and this dark
energy that has really come to the fore
only in the last few years represents
the vast majority of the energy in the
universe so one of the big questions
that we're trying to answer in the
gravity cosmology program is what
comprises ninety-six percent of the
universe
in 1989 the communist regimes of Eastern
Europe fell one after the other in a set
of development so dramatic that some
described them as the end of history
many people expected lifespans in these
countries to increase as new freedoms
and opportunities became available but
consider this after the transition male
life expectancy in the Czech Republic
increased by 2 72 years by 2001 the very
same year in Russia male life expectancy
dropped to barely 59 years it was not
only about alcohol so that's a
difference of 13 years of life on
average per man you would not see that
kind of discrepancy between two
societies is if one had a cure for
cancer and the other the other didn't so
my point is that answering the question
what makes a society successful as an
impact on the length and quality of life
for people around the world the
difference between a successful society
and an unsuccessful society can be as
important as any medical or
technological brain true
and I would submit that perhaps there's
no more important question for people to
solve than the nature of the human mind
the key thing here then in terms of how
you develop a mind is how it is that you
get rid of stuff how is it you throw
away half of the brain what are the
events that lead to that and that really
leads to the fundamental question that
we're asking and that is how does
experience get under the skin to sculpt
the spring it's a marvelous thing that
we use brain development is an active
process it's influenced by a wide range
of factors in life success whether its
measured in social economic status in
health and happiness in the number of
microbes whatever is a proud profoundly
actually it's an interesting question as
to whether that's the case it's
profoundly affected by these factors and
I'm suggesting to you that managing the
way in which these kids develop is the
life insurance policy that you can only
buy once and that's early in life and
that's really the key to understanding
how it is that we are who we are thank
you